alors edou edou célibataire bien non
vous marier oui mais hoover nom est
avancé
le nom usuel de votre femme dont il ou
elle date et lieu de votre mariage
croyez voir si justement c'était ce que
je ferai après monsieur ne copiez pas
par dessus le marché
non non non ça c'est s'il ya une cuisine
que je n'aime pas du tout c'est ma paye
d'infos laziale ma feuille d'impôts mais
jeu et même loin de dominer loin de
doigts millet de moi l'idée de vous
donner des explications cet événement
s'est expliqué des exercices m'en a
reparlé nouvelles complications de la
notice simplificatrice prix mais je
crois pouvoir ici sans une tribu dans ce
faire profiter de mon expérience
ceux qui chaque année comme comme moi
devant leur feuille d'impôt la piste de
paix n'avance pas lisse de peur car si
comme l'a dit gerville dans les ide
comme la vie dire gilles comme la vidéo
de la digue bourvil l'a dit socrate ou
dases fort tu vas nous gâte aux affaires
ohada au gouda daouda diop c'est du
latin
enfin ça veut dire faut du culot pour
réussir et les autres ne doivent pas se
laisser dominer par ce complexe de
qu'une politique et c'est par ce
complexe de l'ue comme la kilbi de l'icb
a culbuté de que vous connaissez bien et
qui les empêchera toujours de bien la
digérer la rédiger et c'est pourquoi moi
qui vous parle je fuis trouvé mon certes
espère c'est mon père pasteur mon père
m'en porte mots
son remplaçant d'ailleurs je lui
demander de bien vouloir jeter un tout
petit recueil un tout petit coup doute
eu un coup de foudre une noyade sur ma
première déclaration la première avec ma
première feuille c'est à dire c'était
pas ma première fait la première à effet
des fat et j'avais fait des pâtes et il
ya des personnes qui ont la plume facile
moi c'est la langue aussi utile
aujourd'hui on n'écrit plus on parle
après la deuxième j'avais déclaré trop
la troisième je n'ai plus rien déclaré
du tout un quatrième j'avais plus de
farine a pas de règle c'était la
septième et je suis le contrôleur était
de vous désirez monsieur si vous êtes
trop longues heures si vous êtes trop
court trop si vous l'êtes
ça tombe bien parce que justement je
crains que vous ne vous soyez vous voyez
vous ne vous soyez foutu de n'ayez paix
erreur dans le retard des poteaux qui se
tournent le report des poteaux à la page
2 voyons d'abord la page un faux dit-il
propriétés bâties je ne vois rien je
disais justement peu moi non plus et non
bâti sa non bâti gens mentent pas et là
et bien là
ah s'il faut payer il faut payer
résidences secondaires et secondaires
une très secondaire mais j'en ai qu elle
en tout cas je n'étais pas forcé de lui
dire que j'avais été à la santé pour ma
mère me que j'avais été à la mer pour ma
santé et personnes à votre service
personne ne vous piché fan moi il me dit
bouffi chez pas de mât vous fait tout
tout seul et non bien sûr j'ai ma femme
et c'est tout je ne sais pas le facteur
l'éboueur dame au ciel que nous sommes
nul ne peut se vanter de se passer des
hommes que je lui dis mais vous cacher
des cachets pardon je vois des salaires
qui sont presque invisibles
vous pouvez pas lui avouer que c'était
les cachets de la radio des retraités
résidions de la radio des réseaux de la
sncf que j'avais frauduleusement doublé
par souci de la vraisemblance déjà votre
compte est bon ce rendez vous qui sont
ailleurs
ah non pas du tout t'as pas tout papa
pas du tout non si c'est la somme en
somme qu'on me sandra de veiller plus
10% après la date il dit ah oui mais
après quelle date
ça j'en sais rien ça dépend du rôle mais
10% c'est sûr
alors là j'ai compris et je n'ai rien
dit je ne me suis pas laissé faire j'ai
filé à la poste et j'ai tout payé d'un
seul coup 10% à à hasnon en ajoutant sur
mon talent sur mon talon monsieur c'est
peut-être un devoir pour tous frau mais
soyez un français moyen de payer ses
pinceaux de ppc ayew de deux casques et
que c'est un devoir envers ses enfants
de ne pas verser un centime de plus et
en costumes comme en pro ce crime seront
encore proches or en bas et vous devez
le savoir vous ce que vous êtes père de
ma fille
vous êtes père de famille comme moi ah
non il faut être bon mais complexé
jamais